uh what are you doing
you're not actually going into an
asteroid field it'd be crazy to follow
us wouldn't we
so you've gotten hooked on sci-fi movies
like interstellar
and modern day explorers like elon musk
and now you're obsessed with the idea of
colonizing and exploring space
so you do some research on how we can
colonize space and boom
it costs too damn much for example if
you're going to take any long duration
flight to say mars
you're going to need a lot of water a
standard bottle of water weighs around 1
pound
and at spacex's rates it costs around 2
500 to launch one water bottle from
earth
now as long as it takes that much money
to launch water building structures and
raw materials into space
space exploration and space colonies are
going to move at a pathetically slow
rate
that's why some aspiring pioneers think
that all you need to solve this problem
is to look up these are all the known
asteroids in our solar system as of
2018.
asteroids contain practically an
unlimited amount of natural resources we
could harvest in space
instead of having to launch it up into
space i think what we're doing here on
earth we're waging war and fighting each
other to pull precious metals and other
resources deemed rare out of the ground
and this is our life down here on this
speck
we call earth and there's this abundance
of materials in the universe
in fact asteroids or space mining to be
specific might just be the gateway the
stepping stone we need
to conquer that final frontier and
according to people like neil degrassi
tyson
if jeff bezos doesn't beat them to it
the first trillionaires will probably be
space miners
and by the way the first trillionaire is
going to be the first person to exploit
space resources on asteroids on comets
so let's explore that next trillion
dollar industry
space mining all great ideas
have a flavor of science fiction
otherwise it's an ordinary idea
and so it has just the right amount of
crazy and just the right amount of hey
that's you know the resources out there
sir the possibility of successfully
navigating an asteroid field is
approximately three thousand seven
hundred and twenty to one never tell me
the odds
one asteroid perhaps maybe uh 30 50 feet
across
could in fact yield billions billions of
dollars
in rewards if you want to get on this
trillion
dollar action before it's too late
you're gonna need some baseline
knowledge on things like rocket science
programming and data science
so if you want a cut of those trillions
if you want to play a role in humanity's
next step
that is where today's video sponsor
comes in brilliant
brilliant allows you to learn all these
things you need for space mining
gravitational physics special relativity
solar energy
through interactive lessons that allow
you to learn visually hands-on instead
of with boring lectures and memorizing
formulas
i myself love watching free educational
videos on youtube
but feels like this are a lot like
working out sure you can learn a little
by watching others work out but if you
don't actively put your brain through
the paces yourself
you're never gonna truly understand this
stuff and brilliant allows you to do
just that their 60
plus courses are all crafted by
award-winning teachers researchers and
professionals from mit
cal tech duke microsoft and more so
future trillionaires you can join over 8
million people learning on brilliant by
going to brilliant.org
jake tran to sign up for free and the
first 200 people that go to that link
will get 20
off their annual premium subscription
that's brilliant.org
jake tran
[Music]
asteroids are clumps of leftover rock
and dust from when the plants were
forming in our solar system
and although mining asteroids may sound
a little far-fetched it's already
happened
[Music]
back in 2005 japan's hayabusa spacecraft
landed on the surface of an asteroid
after a two year flight
the hayabusa dock with the floating rock
for two years collected a tiny sample of
the asteroid along with a ton of data
and started his flight backward returned
to earth in
like lower 2010 this mission is what
really sparked this new space race for
extraterrestrial mining
no longer was space mining science
fiction the technology to harvest space
rocks already exist and all we had to do
was up the scale
so now that we know that it's possible
what kind of asteroids should we be
looking for
that's exactly what the samples of the
hayabusa brought back revealed
yeah so it's more than just harnessing
the asteroid it's
creating an entire business model that
get
gets you access to asteroids in the
first place one type of asteroids are
the ones that contain valuable metals
then gold platinum and others like
palladium iridium and more
these metals happen to be the same ones
we use in our smartphones and other
electronics
metals that create a lot of pollution
and destruction to terrestrially mine
these type of asteroids are thought to
have formed during the formation of
planets like ours
during this formation all that pressure
heats up the planet's matter and turns
it into liquid
the heavier elements like metals
gravitate towards the core much like how
oil and water separate themselves in a
glass of water
and that's why it's hard to find things
like gold and platinum near the surface
of the planet they're mostly located
deep within the earth and the fact that
we need these metals makes them even
more valuable
the theory is these types of asteroids
were the result of planets colliding
together during their formation
where those inner metal cores were
lodged out into space they're like the
fragments of planets that never formed
fully
but many of them all the materials have
already been segregated for us
and so you get the heavy metals in the
center and the lighter
materials in the top you fragment this
body and now you have chunks of
asteroids that are
pure heavy metals platinum iridium
osmium
gold take the asteroid 16 psyche for
example
it has a 140 mile diameter around the
same distance from la to san diego
and 95 percent of it is made up of
metals like iron nickel and maybe even
golden platinum
which bloomberg estimated to be worth a
theoretical 700 quintillion dollars in
today's metal prices
although golden asteroids do sound
tempting the problem with mining
asteroids like these for metals is that
even if you extracted a bunch of metals
by the time you got it back to our
planet you would have already spent more
money than it would it cost just to mine
the materials here
that is where the second type of
asteroids come in c-types
and c-type ashwas contains something
that we have plenty of here but is worth
this weight in gold out in space
water like we talked about earlier if
we're gonna explore and colonize space
we're gonna need a lot of water a lot of
water that's very expensive to launch up
from the ground
what's valuable in space is not the same
thing that's valuable down here for
example
you can ask what is the value of a
gallon of water
already in space that's different from a
gallon of water here on earth when nasa
needs water it's got a whole water up
space with it not only is water vital to
our health and survival
but it also makes for great fuel once
water is extracted from c-type asteroids
its hydrogen and oxygen can be broken
down into hydrogen fuel and oxidizer
that means that the first entrepreneurs
that are able to mine water from
asteroids would be able to sell
something right away in space
that every space traveler will need
if you can extract water from one of the
asteroids then you have water in space
what's that worth to nasa all right if
they if they can provide that to nasa
for less
than what it takes nasa to get these
resources into space to do whatever it
needs to do
in space then that's a business model
right there
with the goal of setting up space gas
stations in low earth orbit
and placing more further and further out
into the cosmos so we can extend our
range
just like how electric cars need a ton
of charges around the country for long
range travel to be possible fuel takes
up 90 percent of the mass of today's
rockets
so someone can devise a way to allow
rocket companies and government agencies
to carry less fuel
making spaceflight drastically cheaper
by refilling in space they will rush to
you with money in hand
once this fuel infrastructure is up and
running by mining these asteroids with
water in them
then setting up colonies mining the
metal-based ashtrays and even setting up
space hotels makes a lot more economic
sense
the first asteroids we tackle would be
near-earth asteroids to keep it easy
that's all fine and dandy but how are we
gonna actually extract these raw
materials from asteroids
mining asteroids is a bit more
complicated than just latching onto it
sticking a drill in and calling in a day
because asteroids are so small they're
held together by just a tiny amount of
gravity
if you land it too hard drilled too hard
pull out too hard
you're gonna risk the asteroids simply
breaking apart around you this means
engineers have to get a little creative
on how they plan on mining
one company paving the way for
extracting water out of asteroids is
called trans astra
there are plans to direct sunlight onto
a concentrated spot on the asteroid with
basically big mirrors
since the gravity is so low this
concentrated sunlight is enough to break
the surface
this turns the water and other chemicals
into vapor and that vapor is collected
and stored as ice
they've already shown this to work on
simulated asteroids and vacuum chambers
here on land
in this clip we excavate a hole while
extracting water and co2 from a sample
of asteroid simulant they're building a
prototype as we speak and if all goes
well
they'll be piggybacking on a spacex
falcon 9 rocket soon to test how a small
version of their craft to make sure it
works in space
once they achieve that proof of concept
they plan on having a full-size craft
capable of mining asteroids up to 30
meters in diameter
and be able to use some of the water it
collects as its own field to navigate to
other asteroids
with the ultimate goal of having a swarm
of these things mimicking the behavior
of bees
bees go out collect pollen and return
home to create honey
but instead of pollen it's asteroids and
instead of honey
it's veal and other commodities
[Music]
when this new space race for
extraterrestrial mining was sparked back
in 2010 when japan's hayabusa craft
returned
a new startup quickly emerged planetary
resources
with its own all-star silicon valley
team and investors like google's eric
schmidt
and filmmaker james cameron not too long
after planetary resources got its own
competitor
deep space industries these two became
the icons of the space mining effort
and for a while what was a sci-fi pipe
change seen as if it might actually
happen
but you can only go so long without
making a profit
and in 2018 planetary resources went
under with deep space industries falling
the year after
there was more focus on the religion of
space than the business of space
one former team member recalled and for
all intents and purposes the space
mining industry was practically dead
but not all hope is lost nasa's
osiris-rex just touched down on an
asteroid named bennu on october 20 2020.
it already successfully collected a
sample of it to return back to earth
and this asteroid happens to be rather
dangerous to us with a 1 in 2 700 chance
of impacting earth between the year 2175
and 2199
japan's second hayabusa 2 craft
collected another sample from another
asteroid on november 2019
and is scheduled to return to earth soon
on december 6 2020
[Music]
which brings us to the reality of space
mining does the chicken come first
or the egg do we focus on making space
flight cheaper first
do we try to build a moon or mars base
first or do we cope with the expensive
cost to try to mine asteroids to make
fuel in space
to make space fight cheaper time will
tell but one thing is for sure
money talks
rockefeller became the richest man in
history and when jeff bezos cracked 200
billion dollars in net worth in august
2020
he only came in at half of what
rockefeller was worth
and how did rockefeller create that
wealth by dominating a new untapped
resource as the first mover
oil the days of oil being the hot new
thing are far behind us
but space mining the person that figures
out how to make a profit doing that
will become the modern day rockefeller
luckily for you there has been no better
time to get a head start in this future
gold rush
to claim that first mover's advantage
the problem is getting into the final
frontier of technology can be rather
daunting and conjures up images of
dreadfully boring classes in school
not with brilliant though brilliant lets
you learn practical math and science in
a new way with fun
interactive explorations to give you the
foundation you need for tomorrow's gold
rush
you can take their exploration on
gravitational physics then you can move
on to their exploration on the physics
of solar energy
then maybe their exploration on
astronomy
and with 60 plus courses including ones
on other big waves we talked about like
quantum computing artificial neural
networks
you can find out what revolutionary
field fits best with you
so claim your piece of that trillion
dollar pie by going to brilliant.org
jake tran to sign up for free and the
first 200 people that go to that link
will get 20
off their annual premium subscription
that's brilliant.org
jake tran with the link below
[Music]
i'll be honest guys this month has been
a little bit rough for me both on the
business and personal side but
i'm hanging in there and it's topics
like these that make me genuinely
excited for the future and it's also
topics like these that make for a
complete
poop show in the comments so have fun
down there
if you're new to this channel and you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more of them click that red subscribe
button below because we make video
essays just like this one
every single week on the most
provocative and thought-provoking stuff
in the world of business and if you want
to get notified when new videos come out
so you can like
try to be like the first comment you can
join our inbox notification squad
with the link below all you have to do
is put in your name email there's no
spam no selling of your information
and if you want behind the scenes stuff
and dating the life kind of stuff you
can follow me on instagram
jaketrend.io that is enough shameless
plugs for now
thank you so much for watching you've
been awesome i've been jake stay
dangerous out there
and i will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
i